You know what,
some of my best friends are funny
ladies.
I mean,
what,
you know,
I don't,
I don't understand.
Maybe they are using maybe when they
talk about women not being funny,
maybe in kind of not in the way they
were,
you know,
young male,
humorous used.
Maybe it's more in a more intelligent
way that women use comedy.
There's all kinds of comedy.
There's will ferrell movies and there's
a Larry David on curby enthusiasm one I
enjoy totally in one.
I just don't.
So I think it's the way you use it.
There was an article written in Vanity
Fair.
I was at Vanity Fair and one of the
women aren't funny.
Well,
I think he was talking about the way
women use humor.
Men Use humor to get something out of
the relationship where women don't use
it that way.
I think that's the difference in every
time I hear about women not being funny.
I think women are terrific.
I think they're equal.
I think everybody's equal in it.
Um,
there are less women comedians around
than there men.
I'd say it's about 20 percent women
comedians compared to men.
I don't know,
maybe I,
maybe because of the work that goes into
it,
it's a very company is very aggressive.
I mean,
it's hard.
You're out every night trying to write
material,
perform material.
So it,
it's,
it's grueling and you have to have that
kind of drive inside of you to do it.
I mean,
to make it,
a lot of these,
these comedians,
comedians are on the road all the time
and it's,
it's not the easiest life and it's not
these life hanging around a clubs every
night also.
So you really want it and be able to,
uh,
to get onstage,
you know,
for at least 10 years and doing that
stuff.
That's a long time.
I like Miss London,
La.
I like Susie Essman.
I like Lynn couplets.
I liked my friend,
joy behar,
judy gold.
I don't want to leave anybody out of
this.
Um,
um,
there were a number of,
of,
of young women around coming up the
ranks,
Jessica Kirson.
So there's a lot of ladies working in
New York.